[Music]
let's go to alex in portland oregon
what's up alex
hi john how are you i'm outstanding how
about you
not too bad
and not too bad
the uh undersell of the year
what's that yeah i i got an interesting
question nobody calls my show cause um
when things uh aren't too bad nobody
does right yeah yeah
[Laughter]
alex how's it going um so
my dad recently just a couple weeks back
had a heart attack and he almost died
okay
and i
feel guilty for not feeling bad about it
um
i'll get to the meat of everything you
want to know my main question is um is
this normal and if it's not
what do i do about it if it is how do i
deal with the guilt of not feeling bad
so when you see him feel bad what does
that mean
tell me about that um i just i don't
feel the sadness that i would expect to
like my parents have been married for 48
years
um the thought of losing my mom makes me
sick to my stomach my dad
almost indifferent
and i didn't have
a i don't i didn't have a great
relationship with him but he was never a
bad dad i just i didn't have that
connection okay
so
what
paint me a picture
in like a sentence or two
what did you expect yourself
to do or to feel
or to experience
in the hypothetical event your dad
almost dies
um i guess i thought i would have just
like
overwhelming sense of grief like i lost
something that you know meant so
incredibly much to me um
and like just like i would with my mom
and that would just break my heart but
yet with him i just i don't know like i
felt sadness but the sadness was for my
mom for
almost losing him yeah you know
so it just i don't know it just it hit
me weird and like i realized when she
called me and told me that she you know
i could hear it in her voice she was
just distraught sure that's what hurt me
so
i don't know once i like started
thinking about it i realized that's what
my sadness was it was for her and
i don't know i've seen him since and you
know he's doing fine he's he had really
high cholesterol and one of his arteries
was almost completely blocked
and he's being incredibly stubborn and
he's saying well it took 67 years for
that artery to walk so now i have
another 67 years he's just being like so
cavalier about it and when he was in the
hospital um he wanted no attention like
he didn't want anyone to know and it was
you know oh don't tell anybody and now
that he's out he loves all the attention
he's getting and he wants to talk about
every little detail and it's just it's a
lot for me i'm like i just i can't you
know here's my guess here's my guess
alex
this isn't just about the heart attack
he's been
this way for your whole life is that
fair
yeah yeah
and it's exhausting and annoying and
it is okay
for whatever it's worth and it i'll tell
you it's not very much
it is okay to not like your dad
okay you can love somebody and not like
them
you can love somebody and respect them
and not want to hang out with them
yeah
here's a couple of things i've learned
working in grief for
forever now um and trauma and tragedy
we have these hollywood pictures of what
happens this evening we've there's even
a lot of research on juries
and when people respond they find their
husband has passed away or their kid has
passed away and they don't respond in a
hollywoodized way they're often looked
at as a suspect
or why did you call this person that
what i will tell you
is that whatever picture you have of you
how you think you're gonna respond
you have no idea none right
most people most of the time
don't scream and yell and weep and fall
down on the floor they go stone numb
they freeze
and they will report things like i can't
feel anything
i can't
i
am just
and that's just their body shutting down
and that's totally normal and okay
what here's here's what i want to to
leave give give you to to carry you on
in the next however many years you're
going to be have your dad with you your
mom with you and just as you learn to
learn about alex more
be curious with your responses
not judgmental of them
okay
so when you have an anticipated response
and you don't respond that way instead
of going oh my gosh i'm broken or i suck
or it's because my dad's
just be curious about it like why in the
world
it helps me to write that stuff down
when i have those different responses
um some people can talk it out with
their friends or with someone they trust
but just be curious about it so let's be
curious why do you think
why do you think that you're indifferent
and it's okay to say i don't like him i
have never liked him
yeah he hurt me growing up
i think
i think it's because i've seen
well for an example um
probably about two months ago
um my mom had covid and shingles at the
same time and she was
almost literally on her deathbed there
was one day though that she thought yeah
i'm i'm done this is it
and she
i don't i'm married i don't live at home
and uh
i knew they were going through this and
i knew she was also a little stubborn
and didn't want to go to the hospital so
i had texted my dad and i said hey
you know if she's refusing to go to the
hospital and you won't [ __ ] up and take
her i'm going to call the police and i'm
going to have a forced welfare check on
her because i don't want her to die
because she's being stubborn right
and
he just said okay thanks for your
concern you know well she's doing okay
blah blah blah blah blah
and
i then find out when she asked him to
call for an ambulance for her on that
day that she thought this was it
he said oh
are you sure i mean you know they're
they're gonna show up and you're gonna
be really embarrassed and you know like
he just he kind of he cares so much
about appearances
not the
severity of the situation and then on
top of that i find out that
when i said that to him that i'm gonna
call the police and have a force check
on her
he laughed he thought that was funny
and i'm just like who does that you know
i just it makes me sick because it's
like you you don't take things seriously
and then you want all the attention
and love in the world when it's about
you yeah
so it just i just
i'm disgusted
really and so here's what i want to tell
you alex it's okay to be disgusted
yeah anger points us to things that we
care about
yeah and that's what it is it was it was
anger and you know all that for how he
treated treated my mom in that situation
how i've seen him treat her you know my
whole life growing up and and and and
how he treated you
how he treated you
you you were the recipient of this as
well
it's okay to be angry it's okay to be
frustrated in a perfect world
you let him know these things while he's
still alive
i've also seen it time and time again
that people pass away and that initial
wave of anger and disgust and
frustration and all that passes
and then there's this longing for almost
for a myth for a fantasy of
i miss my dad
right i miss my dad and
letting him know hey i almost we almost
lost you
and you're cavalier about it
here's somebody who's not cavalier about
you me
and i love you
and i don't like your cavalier attitude
it breaks my heart that you're cavalier
about mom's health about your health
but your dad you're 67 years old you can
do whatever you want
i tell you it breaks my heart
and it's hard to love you i do it's hard
to love you though
and then when it comes back to the
response your response does i mean you
don't need to be curious about it
you know why you don't like the man he
almost killed your mom
in your in your heart and mind he almost
killed your mom
he's been like this whole life you're
just done with him it's cool
you're allowed to be done with him and
i'm gonna tell you down the road this is
gonna come back it's gonna hurt and so
whatever you can process and deal with
now and let go of here's something i
think um that you're carrying around
that would probably be great for your
soul
and
now you should forgive your dad and
put that brick down stop carrying it
i think you've been carrying your old
man for a long long long time
and
he's obviously doesn't have the tools
and some equipment and he's got some
challenges that he's worked through he's
not going to change
and so at the end of the day you're
carrying around the stuff that's not
going to make any difference to him
so i'd set it down and you can set it
down by writing him that letter by
calling him and look at him in the eye
by saying what you need to say or saying
nothing and just saying
i'm putting that down i love my dad and
he's drawn his boundaries and so i'm
gonna draw mine
but that's hard man it's hard hard hard
hard hard in the last year last two
years i've heard more stories of people
coming to the terms with their parents
and who they are and their mortality or
their idiocracy or whatever it happens
to be and
i'm sorry but to answer your original
question you're not broken alex you're
not evil you're not mean it's okay to
not like your dad especially if he's
abusive especially if he's ugly your mom
especially fill in the blank
i always want people to be respectful
and treat their parents with dignity
and it's always okay to just sit down
and say i miss my dad where were you
that's okay too thank you so much for
that call alex